un primer imputado por el magnicidio de
Jove en el Moix el ex militar colombiano
Mario Palacios de 43 años fue
extraditado a Estados Unidos desde
Panamá y tras una primera audiencia
presencial ante una Corte de Miami el
Departamento de Justicia emitió un
comunicado con los dos cargos en su
contra está acusado de conspiración para
cometer asesinato o secuestro fuera de
los Estados Unidos y brindar apoyo
material con resultado de muerte a
Palacios la el eran formalmente los
cargos en una audiencia prevista para el
31 de enero de salir culpable podría
enfrentarse a la cadena perpetua en el
comunicado también se explica que el
complot inicial planeaba secuestrada
presidente Moix pero terminaron
asesinándolo
Mario Palacios formaba parte del Equipo
Delta los 5 encargados de entrar a la
habitación para ejecutar el asesinato
del presidente en total participaron 23
hombres en su mayoría colombianos de los
que hay 18 apresados y 3 murieron en el
tiroteo
magnicidio que según la Oficina del
Primer Ministro cerca estuvo de
repetirse en el primer día de 2022 Ariel
Enric tuvo que ser evacuado de una
iglesia mientras participaba en un acto
de conmemoración del aniversario
218 de la Independencia de Haití desde
el gobierno acusan a bandidos y
terroristas en un ataque en el que murió
una persona y otras dos resultaron
heridas desde el asesinato de mois las
pandillas han ganado fuerza consideran
que la oligarquía cometió el magnicidio
en un país que ve como mente el calvario
de la inseguridad